This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. No matter how many you've been to, it's hard to shake the contagious optimism of weddings, couples vow to love one another in sickness and in health, for richer, for poorer. Family members dabbed tears from their eyes, agreeing that these two people are meant to be together forever. But so many marriages become unhappy, some dissolve, some end in divorce, and even the successful ones aren't without challenges.
这里是《隐形大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。无论你参加过多少场婚礼，都很难摆脱那种婚礼上极具感染力的乐观情绪：夫妻双方誓言无论疾病还是健康、贫穷还是富有，都要相爱相守。家人们擦去眼角的泪水，一致认为这两个人注定要永远在一起。但许多婚姻变得不幸福，有的分崩离析，有的以离婚告终，即使是那些成功的婚姻也并非没有挑战。
No one would deny that long-term relationships are hard. And in fact, there's evidence they're getting harder. Why is that? This week on Hidden Brain, we'll take a closer look at the history of marriage. Most of what we think of as traditional marriage was not traditional at all, but a rather recent invention. We'll also explore the radically higher expectations we have for marriage today. Lots of people argue that having these high expectations is problematic and it's harming the institution of marriage.
没有人会否认长期关系是艰难的。事实上，有证据表明它们正变得越来越难。这是为什么呢？本周在《隐形大脑》节目中，我们将深入探讨婚姻的历史。我们所认为的传统婚姻，大部分根本不是什么传统，而是一个相当近代的发明。我们还将探讨当今人们对婚姻极高的期望。许多人认为，拥有这些高期望是有问题的，它正在损害婚姻制度。
And frankly, among the people who used to argue that is myself. And we'll discuss ways to improve our love lives, sometimes by asking more of our partners and of ourselves, sometimes by asking less. To understand marriage today, we thought it best to go back to a time and place when marriage was very different. Well, I've been studying the history of family life for many, many years, but I specifically got interested in marriage as we got into these debates about what traditional marriage was. That's Stephanie Koons. She's a professor at the Evergreen State College and the author of the book Marriage, a History.
坦率地说，曾经持这种观点的人中就包括我。我们将讨论改善爱情生活的方法，有时是通过对伴侣和自己提出更多要求，有时则是通过减少要求。为了理解今天的婚姻，我们认为最好回到一个婚姻截然不同的时代和地点。我研究家庭生活史已经很多很多年了，但当我开始参与关于什么是传统婚姻的辩论时，我特别对婚姻产生了兴趣。那是斯蒂芬妮·孔茨。她是常青州立学院的教授，也是《婚姻的历史》一书的作者。
Stephanie says the earliest marriages had nothing to do with the feelings of two people or their attraction to one another. As you probably know, marriage was much more about economics and acquiring powerful in laws. It was a way of circulating obligations and goods. I'm marrying my child off to you and that means you owe me things But I also owe you things Stephanie brought up a famous example from history the union between Cleopatra of Egypt and Mark Antony of Rome Elizabeth Taylor as Cleopatra Siren of the Niles. This is from a 1963 film version Richard Burton as Mark Antony from a 1963 film version. The Hollywood version of the story portrays Cleopatra and Antony as being very much in love,
斯蒂芬妮说，最早的婚姻与两个人的感情或彼此的吸引力毫无关系。正如你可能知道的那样，婚姻更多是关于经济和获取有权势的姻亲。这是一种流通义务和商品的方式。我把我的孩子嫁给你，这意味着你欠我东西，但我同时也欠你东西。斯蒂芬妮举了一个历史上的著名例子：埃及艳后克利奥帕特拉与罗马马克·安东尼的结合。这是1963年电影版中伊丽莎白·泰勒饰演的克利奥帕特拉，尼罗河的海妖；理查德·伯顿饰演马克·安东尼。好莱坞版本的电影将克利奥帕特拉和安东尼描绘成深爱彼此，
but Stephanie paints a slightly different picture. I think that the theme song for that relationship could have been what's love got to do with it. What's love got to do with it? They may have been passionate, but it was more passion for power than sexual, although sexual probably entered into it too. Cleopatra and Antony's marriage was primarily about strategy. Rome and Egypt were the two most powerful empires in the world, so getting them, anybody who got them together and had gotten a alliance between them would be unstoppable. The story goes that Cleopatra was married to her brother, and without getting into all
但斯蒂芬妮描绘的画面略有不同。我认为那段关系的背景音乐应该是《爱与它有什么关系》。爱与它有什么关系？他们可能充满激情，但那更多是对权力的渴望，而非性欲，尽管性可能也参与其中。克利奥帕特拉和安东尼的婚姻主要是出于战略考虑。罗马和埃及是世界上最强大的两个帝国，所以任何能将他们联合起来并达成联盟的人都将势不可挡。故事说克利奥帕特拉嫁给了她的兄弟，而不去深究所有
the details, let's just say she wasn't too happy with that. So she started an affair with Julius Caesar, the ruler of Rome. Cleopatra became pregnant. When the baby was born, he was named Cisarian. The child gave Cleopatra and Caesar a claim to each other's throne. It was something they both desperately wanted. Sounds like an episode of Game of Thrones, right? Well, then Caesar died, and Mark Anthony came along. And of course, the story tells that she should dost him. But, you know, when you really look at what was happening practically,
细节，我们只能说她对此并不太高兴。所以她开始与罗马统治者尤利乌斯·凯撒有染。克利奥帕特拉怀孕了。孩子出生时，被命名为凯撒里昂。这个孩子给了克利奥帕特拉和凯撒对彼此王位的要求权。这是他们两人都极度渴望的东西。听起来像《权力的游戏》的一集，对吧？好吧，后来凯撒死了，马克·安东尼出现了。当然，故事说她应该迷住他。但是，你知道，当你真正审视实际发生的事情时，
this was another political alliance. First, as did Caesar. You were marrying me according to Egyptian ritual. It's not a condition that's a reward. You were declared by your authority, Cicerian to begin of Egypt. And we will rule together in his name. Cicerian was too young to rule, and Anthony could rule in his place.
这又是另一个政治联盟。首先，就像凯撒一样。你按照埃及的仪式娶我。这不是一个条件，而是一种奖励。你被你的权威宣布为埃及的凯撒里昂。我们将以他的名义共同统治。凯撒里昂太小无法统治，而安东尼可以代替他统治。
So it was a great big political alliance, just like Game of Thrones. This marriage strategy wasn't just for kings and queens. There's a common misconception that people of lower classes in this time married for love. Not true, Stephanie says. You couldn't run a farm with one person. There's a common misconception that people of lower classes in this time married for love. Not true, Stephanie says. You couldn't run a farm with one person.
所以这是一个巨大的政治联盟，就像《权力的游戏》一样。这种婚姻策略不仅仅针对国王和王后。有一个常见的误解，认为那个时代的下层阶级是为了爱情而结婚。斯蒂芬妮说，这不是真的。你一个人经营不了农场。有一个常见的误解，认为那个时代的下层阶级是为了爱情而结婚。斯蒂芬妮说，这不是真的。你一个人经营不了农场。
You couldn't run a bakery with one person. So people who were bakers married other bakers. If you were a peasant, you wanted somebody who had a good reputation as a hard worker. And that was much more important than this frivolous luxury, as the way it was really thought of, as how attracted you were to the person. A different idea started to become more common in the 17 and 1800s. Jane Austen, the famous novelist, may well have been the trailblazer. For those who don't remember the plot of her book, Pride and Prejudice, Mr. Darcy,
你一个人经营不了面包店。所以面包师会和其他面包师结婚。如果你是农民，你会想要一个以勤劳著称的人。这比那种被视为轻浮奢侈的东西——即你对那个人有多大的吸引力——要重要得多。一种不同的观念在17和18世纪开始变得普遍。著名小说家简·奥斯汀很可能是先驱。对于那些不记得她的小说《傲慢与偏见》情节的人，达西先生，
who has been promised in marriage to his wealthy cousin, falls instead for Elizabeth Bennett, a woman of modest means. That throws his aunt into a rage. Mr. Darcy is engaged to my daughter. Now what have you to say? Only this if that is the case, you can have no reason to suppose he would make an offer to me. You selfish girl! This union has been planned since that infancy! Do you think it can be prevented by a young woman of inferior birth? Heaven and earth, are the shades of pembolity with us polluted? Now tell me once and for all, are you engaged to him?
他曾被许诺娶他富有的表妹，却爱上了伊丽莎白·班内特，一个家境平平的女人。这让他的姨妈勃然大怒。达西先生已经和我女儿订婚了。现在你有什么要说的？只有这一点：如果是这样的话，你没有任何理由认为他会向我求婚。你这个自私的女孩！这个结合从婴儿时期就计划好了！你以为一个出身卑微的年轻女子就能阻止它吗？天哪，彭伯里的阴影被我们玷污了吗？现在最后一次告诉我，你和他订婚了吗？
I am not. So, Stephanie, talk about this. This is the first glimmers, if you will, of the idea that in some ways love was coming to conquer marriage. This clip you used is perfect because it illustrates the fact that men found it easier to embrace the love match than women did. Men could marry down because they could go out and earn wages. Women had to be very, very cautious. You know, as you can say, my heart inclines to Harry, but you know, I'd better marry who my parents want me to and the person who is most likely to be able to support me. And so there was a prolonged period of time where men actually were more romantic than women in the courtship, Aurena. By the second half of the 19th century, the Jane Austen model of marriage had taken firm hold in the United States.
我没有。那么，斯蒂芬妮，谈谈这个。这可以说是爱情在某种程度上开始征服婚姻的最初迹象。你用的这段视频很完美，因为它说明了一个事实：男人比女人更容易接受爱情婚姻。男人可以向下通婚，因为他们可以出去挣工资。女人必须非常非常谨慎。你知道，正如你可以说，我的心倾向于哈里，但你知道，我最好还是嫁给父母希望我嫁的人，以及最有可能养活我的人。因此，在求爱领域，有一段很长的时间里，男人实际上比女人更浪漫。到了19世纪下半叶，简·奥斯汀式的婚姻模式已在美国牢牢扎根。
The idea of marrying for anything other than love came to be seen as old-fashioned, and with the rise of this new idea came another. If marriage was once seen as a partnership between people from similar backgrounds and similar social classes, the new model of marriage began to celebrate the coming together of people who were supposedly radically different from one another. And you got this new theory that love was a union of opposites. Down this idea came that men and women were totally different and you could only have access to the emotions, resources, abilities of the other by getting married and staying married.
为了爱情以外的任何原因而结婚的想法开始被视为过时，随着这一新观念的兴起，又出现了另一种观念。如果说婚姻曾经被视为来自相似背景和社会阶层的人之间的伙伴关系，那么新的婚姻模式开始赞美那些被认为与彼此截然不同的人的结合。于是你得到了这个新理论：爱情是相反者的结合。这种观念认为男人和女人是完全不同的，你只有通过结婚并保持婚姻关系，才能获得对方的情感、资源和能力。
You were incomplete without it. In practice, this dovetail with a changing economic landscape in the country where men increasingly became the breadwinners and women became homemakers. The 1950s sitcom, Leaver to Beaver, makes clear this division between male and female roles. That explains about mom. How come you always do the outside cooking? Well, I'll tell you son, women do all right when they have all the modern conveniences. But us men are better at this rugged type of outdoor cooking. It's sort of a throwback to caveman days. Talked to me by this idea Stephanie, so clearly gender biases played a role in how we came to think about marriage.
没有它你就是不完整的。在实践中，这与国家不断变化的经济格局相吻合，男人越来越多地成为养家糊口的人，而女人则成为家庭主妇。1950年代的情景喜剧《天才老爸俏妈》清楚地表明了这种男女角色的分工。这解释了关于妈妈的事。为什么你总是做户外烹饪？嗯，我告诉你儿子，当女性拥有所有现代便利设施时，她们做得很好。但我们男人更擅长这种粗犷的户外烹饪。这有点像是回到穴居人时代。斯蒂芬妮，谈谈这个想法，很明显，性别偏见在我们思考婚姻的方式中发挥了作用。
Well absolutely, but what's interesting about this clip is that the concept of the male breadwinner was unknown before the 19th century. Women worked in the home, but so did men. And men didn't go out and bring home the bacon. Women helped raise the pig, maybe the man butchered it, but the woman often cured the bacon and took the bacon to market. So again, this was part of this new idea of love that I talked about earlier. The idea that men and women were so different that the man had to do all the outside stuff because the woman couldn't do it and the woman had to do all the inside stuff
嗯，绝对是这样，但这段视频有趣的地方在于，男性养家糊口的概念在19世纪之前是闻所未闻的。女性在家里工作，但男性也一样。男人并没有出去把培根带回家。女人帮忙养猪，也许男人宰杀它，但女人通常会腌制培根并把培根拿到市场上去卖。所以，这再次成为我之前谈到的新爱情观念的一部分。这种观念认为男人和女人是如此不同，以至于男人必须做所有的户外工作，因为女人做不了；而女人必须做所有的室内工作，
because the man couldn't do it and wasn't supposed to do it. The idea of the love match may have been controversial at first, but when concerns were raised about how people from different backgrounds would stay together, when they didn't have the bond of shared work or the larger framework of a shared community, advocates for love marriage said men and women would stay together because they needed one another to feel psychologically complete. This theory was later appropriated in romantic stories and movies. Think of the saying, opposite, subtract. But as the divorce rate in America
因为男人做不了，也不应该做。爱情婚姻的观念起初可能是有争议的，但当人们担心来自不同背景的人在没有共同工作或更广泛的社区框架作为纽带的情况下如何维持在一起时，爱情婚姻的倡导者说，男人和女人会在一起，因为他们需要彼此来获得心理上的完整。这个理论后来被挪用到浪漫故事和电影中。想想那句谚语：异性相吸。但随着美国离婚率
surged in the 1970s and 80s, many started to think that what you should look for in a mate was not your opposite, but someone who shared your interests and values. It wasn't quite the same as one baker looking to marry another baker, but more along the lines of people marrying others with similar educational backgrounds and similar cultural and political attitudes. You know, it's important to understand that love itself, the definition has changed. It's different today than it was at the beginning of the love match when it was a union of opposites.
在1970年代和80年代激增，许多人开始认为，你在伴侣身上寻找的应该不是你的对立面，而是与你志趣相投、价值观相同的人。这并不完全等同于一个面包师想娶另一个面包师，而是更倾向于人们与具有相似教育背景以及相似文化和政治态度的人结婚。你知道，重要的是要理解爱情本身，它的定义已经改变了。它与爱情婚姻刚开始时不同，那时它是相反者的结合。
And today it's really like a union of people who share so many values. And that's one of the big challenges of love today, because we spend 100 years trying to get people to see a difference as erotic and the source of love. And now our big challenge is how do we make equality erotic? How do you make equality erotic? Where is the sizzle in consensus and compromise? In childcare pickups and doctors appointments, in a lifestyle symbolized by a Honda Civic rather than a flashy Ferrari? When we come back, we'll answer that question. We've been talking with historians, Stephanie Koons, about how marriage changed from an institution that was primarily about economic partnerships and political experience to one based on romantic love. Once this shift took hold in
而今天，它更像是分享许多价值观的人的结合。这也是当今爱情面临的巨大挑战之一，因为我们花了100年试图让人把差异视为性感的来源和爱情的源泉。而现在我们面临的巨大挑战是：我们如何让平等变得性感？你如何让平等变得性感？共识和妥协中有什么激情？在接送孩子和看医生中，在以本田思域而非闪亮法拉利为象征的生活方式中？回来后，我们将回答这个问题。我们一直在与历史学家斯蒂芬妮·孔茨讨论婚姻如何从一种主要关于经济伙伴关系和政治经验的制度，转变为一种基于浪漫爱情的制度。一旦这种转变在
the United States over the course of the 19th century, love marriages became the norm. Soon everyone wanted to know the secrets of making love last. You've seen those documentaries and news stories about elderly couples who've managed to stay together for most of their lives. The newest members of a very elite club, Helen and Morris K, 101 and 102 years old, celebrating their 80th wedding anniversary. Meet Milt and Leona, sweet hearts for life. We've been married 60 years, 60 beautiful years.
美国在19世纪的过程中扎根，爱情婚姻就成了常态。很快每个人都想知道让爱情持久的秘诀。你见过那些关于老年夫妇如何设法在一起生活了大半辈子的纪录片和新闻报道。一个非常精英俱乐部的最新成员，海伦和莫里斯·K，101岁和102岁，庆祝他们的80周年结婚纪念日。认识一下米尔特和利奥娜，终身的甜心。我们结婚60年了，60个美好的年头。
When people ask me how long have you been married, I truthfully say not long enough. A heartwarming documentary about the life of a couple that has been together for three quarters of a century, 75 years. There's something that those stories don't tell you. Social psychologist Eli Finkel at Northwestern University has studied the psychological effects of the historical changes that Stephanie has documented. Eli is the author of the All or Nothing Marriage, and he has a very dramatic term for the challenge that many couples face today. Modern marriage, he says, runs the risk of suffocation.
当人们问我结婚多久了，我诚实地说，还不够久。一部关于一对在一起生活了四分之三世纪（75年）的夫妇生活的感人纪录片。这些故事里有些东西没有告诉你。西北大学的社会心理学家伊莱·芬克尔研究了斯蒂芬妮所记录的历史变革带来的心理影响。伊莱是《全或无婚姻》的作者，他为当今许多夫妇面临的挑战提出了一个非常戏剧性的术语。他说，现代婚姻面临着窒息的风险。
To understand that term, Eli says you have to look at yet another shift that started in the 1960s and 70s. We wanted to complement our emphasis on love, achieving love through marriage, with a new emphasis on achieving a sense of personal fulfillment in the way of personal growth. So in the terminology of psychology, we wanted to self-actualize through our marriage, we wanted to grow into a more authentic version of ourselves. One example of this comes from the best-selling book by Elizabeth Gilbert about walking out on her husband and trying to create a more meaningful life for herself. We're going to play a few clips from the movies as we chat, and this one comes from the movie Eat, Pray, Love featuring Julia Roberts. of this life. So why did I see myself in any of it? The only thing more impossible than staying was leaving. It sounds like she was searching for her true selfie line.
要理解这个术语，伊莱说你必须看看从1960年代和70年代开始的另一个转变。我们希望通过一种新的强调个人成长的方式，来补充我们对爱情的强调，即通过婚姻实现爱情。所以用心理学的术语来说，我们想通过婚姻实现自我实现，我们想成长为更真实的自己。一个例子来自伊丽莎白·吉尔伯特关于离开丈夫并试图为自己创造更有意义生活的畅销书。我们在聊天时会播放几段电影片段，这一段来自电影《美食、祈祷和恋爱》，由朱莉娅·罗伯茨主演。这种生活。所以我为什么会在其中看到自己？唯一比留下更不可能的事情就是离开。听起来她是在寻找她真正的自我。
Yeah, that's exactly right. She in some sense helps to epitomize both the strengths and the weaknesses of this modern contemporary approach to marriage, where we're looking to our spouse, again, not only for love, but also this sense of personal growth and fulfillment. And for the first time, you start to see cases where people would say, as I think Liz Gilbert would say, that she was in a loving marriage and he was a good man and treated her well, but she felt stagnant and she really wasn't willing to endure a stagnant life for the next 30 or 40 years and she walked out. This would have been unthinkable, of course, a hundred years ago, let alone 500 years ago.
是的，完全正确。她在某种意义上体现了这种现代婚姻方法的优势和劣势，我们再次向配偶寻求的不仅是爱，还有这种个人成长和成就感。而且你第一次开始看到这样的案例，人们会说，我想利兹·吉尔伯特会说，她处于一段充满爱的婚姻中，他是一个好人，对她很好，但她感到停滞不前，她真的不愿意在接下来的30或40年里忍受停滞的生活，于是她离开了。这在一百年前当然是不可想象的，更不用说五百年前了。
Yes, this would have been a very, very bizarre thing to say. And marriage, you know, it wasn't really until the 70s that you started seeing no fault divorce laws. It used to be that you had to prove some type of serious mistreatment like abuse or desertion. Yes, it's a very modern idea that we are entitled to a sense of real fulfillment and personal growth through the marriage. And if our marriage is falling short, many of us consider it to be a reasonable option to end the marriage for that alone. You come up with what I think of as a riff on a very famous psychological concept.
是的，这会是一件非常非常奇怪的事情。而且婚姻，你知道，直到70年代你才开始看到无过错离婚法。过去你必须证明某种严重的虐待行为，如家暴或遗弃。是的，我们有权通过婚姻获得真正的成就感和个人成长，这是一个非常现代的想法。如果我们的婚姻达不到要求，我们许多人认为仅凭这一点就结束婚姻是一个合理的选择。你提出了一个我认为是对一个非常著名的心理学概念的即兴发挥。
Many years ago, Abraham Maslow proposed that human beings have a series of different needs that begin with physical security and end with a search for meaning and fulfillment. And you say that a similar hierarchy has come to describe how many Americans think about marriage. Tell me about what you call Mount Maslow. Well, one of the most exciting things that happened to me in the process of writing the book is I learned a lot about the history and the sociology and the economics of marriage, particularly
多年前，亚伯拉罕·马斯洛提出人类有一系列不同的需求，从身体安全开始，到寻求意义和成就感结束。你说类似的等级制度已经开始描述许多美国人对婚姻的看法。告诉我你所说的“马斯洛山”。嗯，我在写书的过程中发生的最令人兴奋的事情之一是我学到了很多关于婚姻的历史、社会学和经济学，特别是
reading people like Stephanie Coence, because my primary expertise is as pretty much a laboratory psychologist. I bring couples into the laboratory and I videotape them interacting and I follow them over time. But these other disciplines, scholars and these other disciplines adopt a different approach. So I realized that marriage had in fact changed radically in terms of the way we expect it to
阅读像斯蒂芬妮·孔茨这样的人的作品，因为我的主要专长基本上是一名实验室心理学家。我把夫妇带进实验室，录下他们的互动，并随着时间的推移跟踪他们。但这些其他学科的学者采用了不同的方法。所以我意识到，婚姻实际上在我们需要它满足的方式上发生了根本性的变化，
fulfill our needs in America that is. And it used to be that marriage was about basic economic survival. We've seen that from Stephanie Coons and others. And you can think of that as being at the bottom of Maslow's hierarchy toward the physiological and safety needs, really survival-based needs. And then as we track marriage and it becomes more about love, now we're more toward the middle of Maslow's hierarchy. And then, in the 1960s and then really up until today, we're in this new era where yes, we're still looking for love,
在美国是这样。过去，婚姻是关于基本的经济生存。我们已经从斯蒂芬妮·孔茨和其他人那里看到了这一点。你可以认为这处于马斯洛需求层次的底部，即生理和安全需求，也就是生存需求。然后当我们追踪婚姻时，它变得更多是关于爱，现在我们更接近马斯洛需求层次的中间。然后，在1960年代，一直到今天，我们处于这个新时代，是的，我们仍然在寻找爱，
but now we're toward the top of Maslow's hierarchy, where he's talking about things like esteem and self-actualization. And so our expectations of marriage have basically ascended from the bottom to the top of Maslow's hierarchy over the course of American history. And one of the ideas that emerged, as I was writing this book, is that we can conceptualize Maslow's hierarchy not just in terms of a triangle, but in terms of a mountain, right? And the advantage of thinking of Maslow's hierarchy as a mountain in this way is that it brings to mind a number of metaphors related to mountaineering. And one thing that we know when we climb up a big mountain
但现在我们处于马斯洛需求层次的顶部，他谈论的是尊重和自我实现等事物。因此，在我们美国的历史进程中，我们对婚姻的期望基本上从底部上升到了马斯洛需求层次的顶部。我在写这本书时出现的一个想法是，我们可以不仅从三角形的角度，而且从山峰的角度来概念化马斯洛需求层次，对吧？以这种方式将马斯洛需求层次视为一座山的优势在于，它让人联想到许多与登山相关的隐喻。当我们攀登一座大山时，我们知道的一件事是
is the views get increasingly gorgeous as you get to the top, but the oxygen gets a little thinner. And so having a successful experience way up there at the top requires that you are able to invest a lot of oxygen, either bring extra oxygen with you on the mountain, or invest a lot of time and energy in the marriage to succeed up there. So to continue your analogy, if we want to get to the top of Mount Mads Lowe, but we have failed to bring our oxygen tanks with us Lowe but we have failed to bring
当你到达山顶时，景色越来越壮丽，但氧气变得稀薄了一些。因此，在山顶拥有成功的体验需要你能够投入大量的氧气，要么随身携带额外的氧气，要么在婚姻中投入大量的时间和精力才能在那里取得成功。所以继续你的类比，如果我们想登上马斯洛山顶，但我们没有带上我们的氧气瓶，
our oxygen tanks with us, that's what leads presumably to what you call the suffocation model. That's right, that's right, that is, that is, it's lovely way up there at the top and if we're looking to try to achieve not only this, this sense of love and connection but also this sense of personal growth and authenticity through the marriage, but we're trying to do it on the cheap. That is, we're trying to do it without investing the time, without investing the psychological energy. Then we're left up there at the top of the mountain without the resources that we need in order to succeed. And so that is what gives us this disconnect between where we are on the mountain, the expectations that we're bringing to the marriage and what
那大概就是导致你所说的“窒息模型”的原因。没错，没错，就是这样，山顶上确实很美，如果我们不仅想实现这种爱和联系，还想通过婚姻实现这种个人成长和真实感，但我们试图以廉价的方式做到这一点。也就是说，我们试图在不投入时间、不投入心理能量的情况下做到这一点。那么我们就留在了山顶，却没有成功所需的资源。所以这就是为什么当我们谈论婚姻的窒息时，我所说的就是这种脱节。我喜欢这个类比的地方在于，它几乎使这个心理过程、这种期望的影响变得具体化了。我们所有人都能想象，如果有一天早上突然醒来，决定，你知道，我要跑马拉松或者我要爬一座山，一座非常高的山，而没有任何准备，会是什么样子。
the marriage is actually able to offer us. And that disconnect is what I'm talking about when I talk about the suffocation of marriage. What I love about that analogy is it makes physical almost this psychological process, this effect of our expectations. All of us can imagine what it would be like to suddenly wake up one morning and decide, you know, I'm gonna run a marathon or I'm gonna climb a mountain, a very tall mountain, without really any preparation.
我们会认识到，这不仅很难做到，而且可能鲁莽。这完全正确。我想如果我们考虑一下我们这些天对婚姻的真正要求，就这些期望的雄心而言，那么我们就会意识到，如果我们太累或太懒，不愿投资于关系的质量，那么我们当然无法完成登顶尝试。
And we will recognize that it's not just difficult to do, but potentially foolhardy. That is exactly right. I think if we think about what we're really asking of our marriages these days, in terms of the, you know of our marriages these days, in terms of the ambition of these expectations, then we realize that if we're too tired or lazy to invest in the quality of the relationship, that of course we're not going to be able to make the summit attempt.
当然，我们无法成功满足马斯洛需求层次最高端的那些期望。所以这本书谈了很多关于我们如何能够将我们对婚姻的要求与婚姻现实中能够提供给我们的东西相一致。所以多年来有一些人试图探索和你一样的想法，伊莱。当然，埃丝特·佩雷尔浮现在脑海中。在她著名的TED演讲中，她总结了其中一些挑战，我想给你播放
Of course we're not going to be able to succeed in meeting those expectations toward the very high end of Maslow's hierarchy. And so the book talks a lot about how we can, in fact, align what we're asking of the marriage with what the marriage is realistically able to offer us. So there've been a few people over the years who've tried to explore the same ideas that you have, Eli. Esther Peral, of course, comes to mind. In her famous TED Talk, she summarizes some of these challenges, and I want to play you
一小段视频。所以我们来到一个人面前，我们基本上要求他们给予我们曾经由整个村庄提供的东西。给我归属感，给我身份，给我连续性，但给我超越和神秘，所有这些都在一个人身上。给我安慰，给我连续性，但给我超越和神秘和敬畏，所有这些都在一个人身上。给我安慰，给我边缘，给我新奇，给我熟悉，给我可预测性，给我惊喜，而我们认为这是理所当然的，玩具和内衣会拯救我们。
a short clip. So we come to one person, and we basically are asking them to give us what once an entire village used to provide. Give me belonging, give me identity, give me continuity, but give me transcendence and mystery and all in one. Give me comfort, give me continuity, but give me transcendence and mystery and awe, all in one. Give me comfort, give me edge, give me novelty, give me familiarity, give me predictability, give me surprise, and we think it's a given and toys and lingerie are going to save us with that.
所以我喜欢那段话，伊莱，但你在书中谈到了同样的想法。你给出了一个女人的类比，她曾经向五个不同的朋友寻求她需要的四件重要的事情，但一旦她结婚，她就向丈夫寻求同样的五件事，而他无法提供所有这些，她现在感到不满足。没错。在关于我们如何实现目标的文献中，有一个笨拙的词叫“多重目标性”，这就是指一种手段可以服务于多个目标的想法。例如，当我步行去上班时，这可能同时满足了我去上班的需求，也满足了我呼吸新鲜空气和锻炼的需求。
So I love that passage, Eli, but you talk about the same idea in your book. You give the analogy of a woman who once turned to five different friends, for important things she needed, but once she gets married, she turns to her husband for those same five things and he's not able to provide all of them and she feels now unfulfilled. That's right. In the research literature on how we achieve our goals, there's a clunky word called multi-finality and this is the idea that a given means can serve multiple goals. So for example, when I walk to work, that might simultaneously meet my need to get to work, but also my needs to get some fresh air and get some exercise.
所以这一个活动可以服务于各种功能。有趣的是，这正是我们对婚姻所做的事情。婚姻在很长一段时间里为我们服务于一套相对有限的不同功能。随着时间的推移，我们堆积了越来越多的这些情感和心理功能。所以，我们不再向亲密朋友和其他亲戚寻求夜晚外出，
And so this one activity can serve all sorts of functions. What's interesting is that's really what we've done to marriage. Is that marriage for a long time served as set and relatively limited array of different functions for us? And over time, we've piled more and more of these emotional and psychological functions. So instead of turning to our close friends and other relatives for nights out on the town,
寻求深度的亲密披露，在越来越大的程度上，我们的配偶取代了我们过去寻求更广泛的社交网络来帮助我们做的事情。你知道，当我读你的书时，伊莱，我意识到不仅我们对伴侣的期望在改变。我们现在也期望我们能解锁伴侣身上的特殊东西。这也反映在电影中。1997年的电影《尽善尽美》有一个场景，一个受够了的女人，
for deep intimate disclosure, to a larger and larger extent, our spouse has replaced a lot of what we used to look to our broader social network to help us do. You know, as I read your book, Eli, I realize that it's not just what we expect from our partners that's changing. We also now expect that we can unlock special things in our partners. And this is also reflected in the movies. The 1997 movie as good as it gets has a scene where a woman who is fed up with,
你知道，被试图追求她的男人贬低，要求他给她一个赞美。好吧。我来了。显然是个错误。我有这个，什么？赞美。我的医生，我过去常去看的心理医生，他说在50%或60%的病例中，药丸真的有帮助。我讨厌药丸。我的赞美是，那天晚上你过来告诉我，你永远不会……
you know, put down by her, by the man who's trying to woo her, demands that he give her a compliment. Okay. Here I go. Clearly a mistake. I've got this, what? Alment. My doctor, a shrink that I used to go to all the time, he says that in 50 or 60% of the cases, a pill really helps. I hate pills. My compliment is, that night when you came over and told me that you would never...
是的。好吧，你在那里。你知道你说了什么。嗯，我对你的赞美是……第二天早上，我开始吃药了。我开始吃药了。我不明白这怎么是对我的赞美。你让我想要成为一个更好的男人。
Yeah. All right, well, you were there. You know what you said. Well, my compliment to you is... The next morning, I started taking the pills. I started taking the pills. I don't quite get how that's a compliment for me. You make me want to be a better man.
那可能是我一生中最好的赞美。在你的书的背景下，我发现这太有启发性了，伊莱，海伦·亨特的角色告诉杰克·尼科尔森的角色，让她感觉真正好的不是他为她做了什么，而是她能做些什么来解锁他身上特别的东西。是的，他被她迷住了，他对她的渴望，他对她的印象深刻以及想要让她更喜欢他的愿望，实际上让他想要成长为一个更好的人。在某种意义上，这就是绝对的原型
That's maybe the best compliment of my life. I found this so revealing in the context of your bookie lie, Helen Hunt's character is telling Jack Nicholson's character that the thing that makes her feel really good is not what he does for her, but what she can do to unlock something special in him. Yeah, he is smitten with her and his desire for her, his being impressed with her and the desire to make her like him more, actually makes him want to grow into a better person. And in some sense, that's the absolute archetype
我们在当代婚姻中看到的。今天，我们正在寻找一个配偶来带出我们理想的版本，那个潜伏在我们体内的版本，我们希望通过足够的时间和努力成长为那个版本。你的书中有一个很棒的术语。你称之为“米开朗基罗效应”。是的，这是一个我实际上从我的博士导师卡罗尔·鲁斯博特那里得到的术语。你们的许多听众会知道，米开朗基罗在谈论雕刻过程时，谈论的不是揭示或雕塑，而是谈论将其从岩石中释放出来
of what we see in contemporary marriage. Today, we're looking for a spouse to bring out the ideal version of us, the latent version that's inside of us, that we can hopefully grow into with enough time and effort. You have a wonderful term in your book. You call this the Michelangelo effect. Yeah, this is a term I actually got from my doctoral advisor, Carol Russbalt. Many of your listeners will know that Michelangelo, when he talked about the sculpting process, talked not in terms of revealing or sculpture, but in terms of unleashing it from the rock
它一直在沉睡。所以雕塑家的工作不是创造新的东西，而仅仅是精炼、打磨和抛光，也许刮掉岩石中已经嵌套的东西的粗糙边缘。对于今天的伴侣如何尝试与彼此相处，这是一个非常好的隐喻。也就是说，我们所有人都有一个真实的自我，即我们目前的样子，但我们也有一个理想的自我，一个有抱负的自我版本。比如，如果我能成为最好的自己，我可能会变成什么样？我们期待伴侣成为我们的雕塑家，
in which it's been slumbering. So the sculptor's job is not to create something new, but merely to refine and buff and polish and maybe scrape away the rough edges of what was already nesting within the rock. That's a really good metaphor for how partners today try to relate to each other. That is, all of us have an actual self, the person that we currently are, but we also have an ideal self, a version of ourselves that's aspirational. Like, what could I maybe become if I could be the best version of myself? And we look to our partners to be our sculptors,
帮助我们，直到我们真正成长为我们最好的理想版本。所以伊莱，我们真的有这种力量吗？这种放置文化并带出别人最好一面的力量？答案是肯定的，我们确实有这种力量，但这并不容易做到，而且并非每个人都兼容。有时你想成长成的版本并不是我希望你成长成的版本。这是我们玩的一场非常微妙的舞蹈。今天最好的关系，我称之为“全”关系和“全或无婚姻”理念的关系，它们在
to help us until we actually grow toward the best ideal version of ourselves. So Eli, do we actually have this power, this power to place culture and bring out the best in someone else? The answer is yes, we do have this power, but it's not easy to do and not everybody is compatible. And sometimes the version of you that you want to grow into isn't the version of you that I want you to grow into. And this is a very delicate dance that we play. And the best relationships today, the sorts of relationships that I call the all relationships and the idea of the all or nothing marriage, they're well
这个意义上是协调一致的。它们能够带出彼此最好的一面，并以促进彼此个人成长的方式连接，从而有助于产生非常深刻的情感联系和心理满足感。许多婚姻专家说，高期望是婚姻幸福的敌人。你得出了一个略有不同的结论。你说，虽然平均而言，今天许多婚姻可能比半个世纪前更不幸福，但这并不适用于所有婚姻。例外是谁？例外是那些带来这些期望
aligned in this sense. They're able to bring out the best in each other and connect in a way that facilitates each other's personal growth and therefore helps to produce a really profound amount of emotional connection and psychological fulfillment. Many marriage experts say that high expectations are the enemy of happiness in marriage. You come to a slightly different conclusion. You say that it's true that on average, many marriages might be unhappy today than they were half a century ago, but that isn't true of all marriages. Who are the exceptions? The exceptions are people who bring those expectations
并且能够满足它们的人。我认为这是整个问题的症结所在。许多人认为拥有这些高期望是有问题的，它正在损害婚姻制度。坦率地说，曾经持这种观点的人中就包括我。我，当我着手写这本书时，以为我写的是关于婚姻随时间衰落的书，以及我们如何将越来越多的期望压在这个制度上
and are able to meet them. And this is, I think, the crux of the entire issue. Lots of people argue that having these high expectations is problematic and it's harming the institution of marriage. And frankly, among the people who used to argue that, is myself. I, when I set out to write this book, thought I was writing a book about the decline over time in marriage and how we're throwing more and more expectations on this one institution
和这段关系上，但我们投入的时间不够，因此我们确实创造了一种严重有问题的婚姻方法，直到我回顾了这些其他科学文献并了解了事情是如何变化的，我才意识到这实际上只是故事的一半。确实，我们要求得更多，特别是在这些更心理和基于爱的需求方面，比过去更多。但有些婚姻能够满足这些需求。那么，如果你拥有一段你希望满足这些最高水平需求的婚姻，例如在
and this one relationship, but we're not investing enough time, and therefore we've really created a seriously problematic approach to marriage, and it wasn't until I reviewed these other scientific literatures and learned more about how things have changed that I realized that's really half the story. It is true that we are asking a lot more, especially when it comes to these more psychological and love-based needs than we did in the past. But some marriages are able to meet those needs. And so what does it mean if you have a marriage that you're looking for to meet these very highest level needs, say for example in
马斯洛需求层次中，而婚姻成功地做到了这一点，这意味着什么？你能够在婚姻中达到一种在那个我们甚至没有尝试满足这些类型需求的时代无法企及的满足感。所以，虽然这些高期望让我们感到沉重，使我们更难实现健康的婚姻，但与此同时，一段在1950年对我们来说可以接受的婚姻，在今天却让我们感到失望，
Maslow's hierarchy, and the marriage succeeds in doing so? You're able to achieve a level of fulfillment in the marriage that would have been out of reach in an era where we really weren't even trying to meet those types of needs. So at the same time that these high expectations are waiting us down and making it more difficult to achieve a healthy marriage at the same time, that a marriage that would have been acceptable to us in 1950 is a disappointment to us today
因为这些高期望。同样的期望使我们触及了一种直到最近才无法企及的婚姻满足感。所以，有些人以牺牲事业和朋友，甚至可能是他们孩子的活动为代价，在婚姻中投入大量资金的想法，你说这在另一部电影的场景中得到了完美的体现。在《杯酒人生》中，保罗·吉亚玛提饰演的葡萄酒鉴赏家向
because of these high expectations. Those same expectations have placed within reach a level of marital fulfillment that was out of reach until pretty recently. So this idea that some people invest heavily in their marriages at the expense of careers and friends, maybe even, you know, their children's activities, you say this is perfectly captured in a scene from another movie. In sideways, Paul Jermade's wine connoisseur character explains
他的爱慕对象解释了黑皮诺和赤霞珠之间的区别。这是一种很难种植的葡萄。你知道，对吧？所以，它皮薄，脾气暴躁，成熟得早。它不像赤霞珠那样是幸存者，赤霞珠可以在任何地方生长，即使被忽视也能茁壮成长。不，黑皮诺需要不断的照顾和关注。你知道，事实上，我只能在世界上这些非常具体的小角落里生长。只有最耐心和最细心的种植者才能真正做到。只有真正花时间了解黑皮诺潜力的人才能诱导它发挥出最充分的表现。然后我的意思是，它的味道，它们只是
to his love interest, the difference between a Pino and a Cabernet. It's a hard grape to grow. As you know, right? So, it's thin skin, temper metal, ripens early. It's not a survivor like Cabernet, which can just grow anywhere and thrive even when it's neglected. No, peanut needs constant care and attention. You know, in fact, I can only grow in these really specific little tucked away corners of the world. And only the most patient and nurturing of growers can do it, really. Only somebody really takes the time to understand Pino's potential can then coax it into its fullest expression. Then I mean, it's flavors, they're just the
地球上最令人难忘、最辉煌、最令人兴奋、最微妙和最古老的。所以当然，伊莱，当我们听到这个并从婚姻的背景下思考它时，为什么我们不都想种植黑皮诺呢？嗯，我认为我们很多人应该对黑皮诺非常小心。我的意思是，我认为那段视频在提供关于美国过去50年或更长时间里婚姻如何变化的类比方面做得非常出色。
most haunting and brilliant and thrilling and subtle and ancient on the planet. So of course, Eli, when we hear this and we're thinking about this in the context of marriage, why wouldn't we all want to grow Pino? Well, I think a lot of us should be pretty careful about Pino. I mean, I think that clip does an absolutely masterful job of providing an analogy to how marriage has changed in America in the last say 50 years or more.
它已经从一种类似于赤霞珠的制度，即可以在任何地方生长并在被忽视时也能茁壮成长，转变为一种更微妙、更脆弱的制度，需要大量的照料和维护。所以你问我，谁会想要除了黑皮诺以外的任何东西，至少根据迈尔斯对那些葡萄的看法。我会说，很多人可能不想处理那种脆弱和娇嫩的东西，
It's changed from an institution approximating Cabernet, which can just grow anywhere and thrive even when it's neglected, to a much more delicate, fragile institution that requires a lot of tending and maintenance. So you ask me, who would ever want anything other than, than Pinot Noir, at least according to how Miles thinks about those grapes. And I would say a whole lot of people might not want to deal with something that fragile and delicate,
但就像他说的，那些做对的人，也就是说，他在谈论葡萄，那些做对的人，也就是说，他在谈论葡萄，当有合适的种植者和合适的背景时，味道只是令人难忘、辉煌、微妙和古老的。我认为他想说的是，这是一种需要高维护的葡萄。它需要大量的工作，如果你不小心和专注，你就会对它感到失望。它会让你失败。但如果你足够努力，你可以拥有真正精致的东西。这就是我们今天所处的“全或无婚姻”的境地。你书中的结论之一是，我们以某种方式有两个主要的替代方案，当涉及到处理
but like he says, those of us who get it right, that is, and he's he's talking about the grapes, those of us who get it right, that is, and he's talking about the grapes, when there's the right grower and the right context, the flavors are just haunting and brilliance and subtle and ancient. And what I think he's saying is, this is a high maintenance grape. It takes a lot of work, and if you aren't careful and attentive, you're going to be disappointed in it. It's going to fail you. But if you work hard enough, you can have something truly exquisite. And that is where we are today, with the Aller-Nothing Marriage. One of the conclusions of your book is that we have, in some ways, two major alternatives, when it comes to dealing with
这个挑战时，我们许多人想站在马斯洛山顶，但没有投入时间、精力和耐心去真正到达那里。在你自己的婚姻中，你描述了一次去西雅图的旅行，在你自己的类比中，你发现自己缺氧了。没错。我们经历了一段艰难的时期。我，特别是，在适应为人父母的过程中经历了一段艰难的时期。而且，坦率地说，我认为我经历艰难时期的原因是，我在书中谈论的那种东西。我没有充分校准或重新校准我对新生儿生活会是什么样子的期望。关于这一点的研究实际上很棘手。显然，拥有一个快乐的结晶是一件美妙的事情，你疯狂地爱着那个新宝宝。
this challenge that many of us want to be at the top of Mount Maslow but are not investing the time and effort or the patience to actually get there. In your own marriage you describe a trip to Seattle where in your own analogy you found yourself starved of oxygen. That's right. We went through a hard time. I, in particular, went through a hard time with the adjustment to parenthood. And I, frankly, I think that the reason I had a hard time is the sort of stuff that I'm talking about in the book. I hadn't sufficiently calibrated or recalibrated my expectations to what life would be like with a newborn. And the research on this is, in fact, tricky. Obviously having a bundle of joy is a wonderful thing, and you love the new baby like crazy
我们许多人都想登上马斯洛金字塔的顶端，却不愿投入时间、精力和耐心去真正实现它，这就是我们面临的挑战。在你自己的婚姻中，你描述了一次西雅图之旅，用你自己的比喻来说，你当时感到缺氧。没错。我们经历了一段艰难的时期。我个人在适应为人父母的过程中经历了一段困难时期。坦白说，我认为我之所以感到困难，正是因为我在书中提到的那些原因。我没有充分地校准或重新校准我对新生儿生活会是什么样子的期望。事实上，关于这方面的研究很复杂。显然，拥有一个可爱的小生命是一件美妙的事情，你会疯狂地爱上这个新生儿。
and kissing that little fuzzy head is one of the most satisfying things we ever get to do in our lives. But the reality is a recent estimate suggests that it's about 33 and a half additional hours a week of extra time. Like I've carried the goes into that. And I would ask the couples out there listening who don't have a kid, where would those 33.5 hours a week come from? And then you're complimenting that with some sleep deprivation and frankly much less time
亲吻那个毛茸茸的小脑袋是我们一生中最令人满足的事情之一。但现实情况是，最近的一项估计表明，这每周大约需要额外增加33个半小时的时间。就像我所经历的那样。我会问那些正在收听节目的没有孩子的夫妇，这每周33.5个小时从哪里来？然后你还要加上睡眠不足，坦率地说，留给你们夫妻间情感交流或性生活的时间也少多了。
for emotional connection or sexual connection with your spouse. And is it any surprise that the research evidence shows that the arrival of the first baby tends to be pretty hard on the quality of the relationship, on the marital satisfaction, for example. And it was during that period where we took a trip to Seattle to see my closest and longest- term friend. One of these life experiences that has always been a source of bliss and joy for me throughout the 30-some-odd years of my life at the time. And I was miserable. It turns out that traveling across the country with an eight-month-old is not anything like
而研究证据表明，第一个孩子的到来往往会对关系质量，例如婚姻满意度产生相当大的冲击，这难道令人惊讶吗？正是在那段时间里，我们去西雅图看望了我最亲密、交往时间最长的朋友。这是我当时三十多年人生中一直给我带来幸福和快乐的生活经历之一。但我却感到非常痛苦。事实证明，带着一个八个月大的孩子跨越全国旅行，和
traveling across the country without an eight-month-old. And then you're together with your best friend, and there's all the stuff that you used to do, but now there's an eight month old there, and you're not doing any of those things. And I really had a hard time. I mean, I can't really exaggerate this. I really struggled emotionally with the adjustment.
不带八个月大的孩子跨越全国旅行完全是两码事。当你和最好的朋友在一起时，你们过去常做的那些事情，现在因为有个八个月大的孩子在场，你们一件也做不了。我真的很难受。我的意思是，我无法夸大这种感受。我在适应过程中确实在情感上挣扎了很久。
And I said to my wife, and I regret saying this, it's hard for me to say out loud right now, I can endure this. Like I regret saying, it's hard for me to say out loud right now, I can endure this. I can get past this and I certainly love my daughter, but I need to stop trying to have fun because if I'm trying to enjoy my life and I'm trying to enjoy you, I keep end up disappointed. And she was very upset about that. And I made her cry, I'm not proud of this at all,
我对妻子说——我很后悔说了这些，现在大声说出来对我来说很难——我能忍受这一切。就像我后悔说的那样，现在大声说出来对我来说很难，我能忍受这一切。我能挺过去，我也确实爱我的女儿，但我需要停止尝试去寻找乐趣，因为如果我试图享受我的生活，试图享受和你在一起的时光，我最终只会感到失望。她对此非常难过。我让她哭了，我一点也不以此为荣，
but she cried and thought, what, is this the end of us trying to live a good life together? Are we just going to hunker down and be unhappy together? But the truth is, this ended up being the lowest point, but also the starting of where I started to recover a little bit. It took that moment before I started to get serious about making life better again. And one of the major ways I did it was by recalibrating my expectations, yes, but also
但她哭了，心想，难道这就是我们努力过好日子的终点吗？我们难道就要这样缩在一起，一起过得不开心吗？但事实是，这最终成了最低谷，但也成了我开始稍微恢复的起点。在那一刻之后，我才开始认真考虑如何让生活重新好起来。我所做的主要方式之一是重新调整我的期望，是的，但同时也
reinvesting in a way that made sure that I was more connected to my wife than we had been, and it took some work. And it did require that we lower expectations in some ways and then try to meet those lower expectations. And we were, in fact, able to to do it but it certainly wasn't easy. Eli and other researchers have found that it's not especially easy to fulfill a partner's emotional and psychological needs when you're struggling to pay the bills or working three jobs. This might be one reason that the institution of marriage appears to be especially fragile
以一种确保我与妻子的联系比以往更紧密的方式进行再投入，这需要一些努力。这确实要求我们在某些方面降低期望，然后尝试去满足那些较低的期望。事实上，我们确实做到了，但这绝非易事。伊莱和其他研究人员发现，当你为生计发愁或身兼三职时，要满足伴侣的情感和心理需求并非易事。这可能是婚姻制度看起来特别脆弱的原因之一
among low-income couples. When we come back, we're going to look at tangible solutions. If you're kind of for to take your partner on that romantic trip to Paris, but you still want to get to the top of Mount Maslow, I'm going to ask Eli for simple hacks to get you there. There. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. On today's show... Marriage! Marriage is what wins us together today.
在低收入夫妇中。回来后，我们将探讨切实可行的解决方案。如果你想带你的伴侣去巴黎进行那场浪漫之旅，但你仍然想登上马斯洛金字塔的顶端，我会向伊莱请教一些简单的技巧来帮你实现。这就是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在今天的节目中……婚姻！婚姻就是今天将我们联系在一起的东西。
That's right. Marriage. Marriage that lesser arrangement... that dream... within our dream. The priest from that iconic scene in the Princess Bride describes it best. What does he? We're taking a look at how marriage has evolved over time from a partnership of necessity
没错。婚姻。婚姻，那种次要的安排……那个梦想……梦想中的梦想。电影《公主新娘》中那个标志性场景里的牧师描述得最好。他说了什么？我们正在审视婚姻是如何随着时间的推移，从一种必要的伙伴关系
to a union of two very different people who need one another's love to be complete to the all or nothing relationships identified by psychologist Eli Finkl. Eli argues that our expectations for marriage, both gay and straight, among rich and poor, have dramatically increased. Couples who are able to meet these higher expectations are happier than couples have ever been, but couples who fall short are unhappier than their counterparts a century ago. Eli says there are things we can do, what he calls love hacks, to reorient how we think about marriage and make ourselves more fulfilled in long-term relationships.
演变成两个非常不同的人的结合，他们需要彼此的爱才能完整，直到心理学家伊莱·芬克尔所定义的“全或无”关系。伊莱认为，我们对婚姻的期望，无论是同性还是异性，无论贫富，都已大幅提高。能够满足这些更高期望的夫妇比以往任何时候都更幸福，但达不到期望的夫妇却比一个世纪前的同类更不幸福。伊莱说，我们可以做一些他称之为“爱情黑客”的事情，来重新定位我们对婚姻的思考方式，使我们在长期关系中感到更加满足。
Some of your listeners might be fans of Marcel Proust who argues that mystery is not about traveling to new places, but about looking with new eyes. And the love hacks are exactly that. There are ways that we can try to experience the same relationship, but view it in a different way, and therefore be a little bit happier in the relationship itself. So psychologists have long talked about something called the fundamental attribution era, which is sometimes when we see someone behave in a way that we don't like, there's two ways to interpret it. You can either say this person is behaving badly because they're a bad person, or you can say this person is behaving badly because there's something in the context. There's something happening around Him or her that's causing Him or her to behave this way. And one of the hacks that you suggest is to reinterpret negative behavior from your partner in a way that's more sympathetic rather than critical. Right.
你们的一些听众可能是马塞尔·普鲁斯特的粉丝，他认为神秘感不在于去新的地方旅行，而在于用新的眼光去看待。而“爱情黑客”正是如此。这些方法可以让我们尝试体验同样的关系，但以不同的方式看待它，从而在关系本身中获得一点点快乐。心理学家长期以来一直在谈论一种叫做“基本归因错误”的东西，即有时当我们看到某人的行为方式我们不喜欢时，有两种解释方式。你要么说这个人表现不好是因为他是个坏人，要么你可以说这个人表现不好是因为环境中有某种原因。他或她周围发生了一些事情导致他或她以这种方式行事。你建议的技巧之一就是以一种更同情而不是批评的方式重新解读伴侣的负面行为。没错。
And I'm not saying it's magic. I'm not saying it's the easiest thing to do, but I'm saying that with some effort we can get a little better at this. So your spouse is late. Your spouse is disrespectful. I mean, ideally not in a huge way, but your spouse does something inconsiderate, you have a lot of control over how that behavior affects you. And in particular, you have control over whether you want to explain that behavior in
我不是说这是魔法。我不是说这是最容易做到的事情，但我想说的是，只要付出一些努力，我们就能在这方面做得更好。所以你的配偶迟到了。你的配偶不尊重人。我的意思是，理想情况下不是那种严重的方式，但你的配偶做了一些不体贴的事情，你对这种行为如何影响你有很大的控制权。特别是，你有权决定是否要用
terms of something about your spouse that's maybe stable and and a character or a logical assessment, like my spouse is always such a jerk, you can try instead to say, look, my spouse was a jerk just now, but he's under a lot of stress at work, or you can think, look, he probably tried the best he could, there was probably some traffic or some crisis at work, I'm just gonna let it ride.
某种关于你配偶的、可能是稳定的、性格上的或逻辑上的评估来解释这种行为，比如“我的配偶总是这么混蛋”，你可以试着说：“看，我的配偶刚才确实很混蛋，但他工作压力很大”，或者你可以想：“看，他可能已经尽力了，可能遇到了交通堵塞或工作上的危机，我还是算了吧。”
Now, I'm not saying these are easy things to do because we do have a default to explain other people's behaviors as elements of their character. But the fact is, and we should be better at understanding this, there are all sorts of things that contribute to why somebody engaged in one behavior over another behavior. And we have some control over the extent to which we interpret our partners in consider
现在，我并不是说这些事情很容易做到，因为我们确实默认将他人的行为解释为他们性格的组成部分。但事实是，我们应该更好地理解这一点，有各种各样的因素导致某人从事某种行为而不是另一种行为。我们可以在一定程度上控制我们如何解读伴侣的
it a rude behavior in a way that's more generous and kind, and the kinder approach will make us happier in the relationship and our partner will probably be happier too. You also think that having what you call a growth mindset is a useful thing. What do you mean by that? So the psychologist Carol Dweck at Stanford, she's developed this idea that people differ in terms of how they think about various attributes. So she studies intelligence, for example. And people differ in the extent to which they think intelligence is something that's fixed and stable and you have it or you don't. Versus,
不体贴和粗鲁的行为，以一种更慷慨和友善的方式去解读，这种更友善的方法会让我们在关系中更快乐，我们的伴侣可能也会更快乐。你还认为拥有所谓的“成长型思维”是有用的。你是什么意思？斯坦福大学的心理学家卡罗尔·德韦克提出了一个观点，即人们在思考各种属性的方式上存在差异。例如，她研究智力。人们在认为智力是固定的、稳定的、你拥有它或者没有它的程度上存在差异。而与之相对的是，
it's malleable and it's something that you can develop over time. Well, it turns out there's a lot of good research now on the extent to which people feel like compatibility in a relationship is something that is fixed. You could call this a destiny mindset. People who think, look, partners are either compatible or they're not, and that's the end of the story, versus more of a growth-oriented mindset. Who think, look, there's a lot of room where you can develop compatibility, and in fact, going through difficulties in a relationship isn't a signal that, oh my goodness, we're incompatible people. It's an opportunity to learn to understand each other better and strengthen the relationship through the resolution of the conflict.
它是可塑的，是可以随着时间发展的。事实证明，现在有很多关于人们认为关系中的兼容性是否是固定的研究。你可以称之为“宿命论思维”。认为“看，伴侣要么兼容，要么不兼容，故事到此为止”的人，与更倾向于“成长型思维”的人相比。后者认为，“看，有很多空间可以发展兼容性，事实上，经历关系中的困难并不是一个信号，说明天哪，我们是不兼容的人。这是一个学习更好地了解彼此，并通过解决冲突来加强关系的机会。”
And here again, it's not like we have complete control over the thoughts that we have about these things, but we can try to make ourselves adopt a more constructive growth-oriented approach to thinking about conflict in the relationship, rather than a more destiny-oriented approach that can often view conflict as a deep sign of incompatibility, and that's pretty destructive for the relationship. destructive for the relationship. You also talk about more serious alternatives, so if people find over time that they are just incompatible with one another, and yet they have these high expectations of different things they want from their life, you suggest that one of the alternatives might be to develop
在这里，我们并不是说我们能完全控制我们对这些事情的想法，但我们可以尝试让自己采取一种更具建设性的、以成长为导向的方法来思考关系中的冲突，而不是那种往往将冲突视为不兼容的深刻标志的宿命论方法，这对关系来说通常是破坏性的。对关系来说是破坏性的。你还谈到了更严肃的替代方案，所以如果人们随着时间的推移发现他们确实彼此不兼容，但他们对生活想要的东西又有很高的期望，你建议其中一个替代方案可能是发展
systems where people are actually getting different things from different people That's right. It's the same logic again, right? So we have this all or nothing approach. We expect these high-level things and Many of our marriages are in fact falling short of that. So one possibility is that we Try to invest more in the relationship and the second possibility, which we've called love hacks is how to be more efficient try to invest more in the relationship and the second possibility, which we've called Love Hacks, is how to be more efficient. But the third possibility, and I actually think we should be pretty serious about this. There's nothing shameful about making these sorts of sacrifices. We should ask less.
人们实际上从不同的人那里获得不同东西的系统。没错。逻辑是一样的，对吧？所以我们有这种“全或无”的方法。我们期望这些高水平的东西，而我们的许多婚姻实际上并没有达到这一点。所以一种可能性是我们尝试在关系中投入更多，第二种可能性，我们称之为“爱情黑客”，是如何更有效率地尝试在关系中投入更多。但第三种可能性，我实际上认为我们应该非常认真地对待这一点。做出这种牺牲并没有什么可耻的。我们应该少要求一点。
In what ways can we, in our own marriage, look to the relationship and see, man, like I have been looking to fulfill this sort of need in the relationship for a long time, and I'm chronically a little disappointed about how we do as a couple and helping to fulfill this sort of need, is there some other way that I might be able to meet this need I have, either through some other friends or even on my own? And there's some research by the the psychologist Elaine Chung at Northwestern University that looks at what she calls social diversification. Can you diversify your social portfolio, if you will?
我们可以在自己的婚姻中以什么方式审视这段关系，然后想：“天哪，我长期以来一直试图在关系中满足这种需求，而我们作为一对夫妇在满足这种需求方面一直有点令人失望，有没有其他方式可以满足我的这种需求，无论是通过其他朋友还是我自己？”西北大学的心理学家伊莱恩·钟（Elaine Chung）有一些研究，着眼于她所谓的“社会多样化”。你可以让你的社交组合多样化吗？
And she looks at the people we turn to when we're feeling emotions that can help us regulate those emotions. So, to whom do you turn when you're feeling sad? To whom do you turn when you want to celebrate your happiness? And she assesses how much people look to a relatively small number of people to do all of those things, versus a larger number of people. And she finds across a range of studies now
她观察了我们在感到情绪时求助的人，这些人可以帮助我们调节这些情绪。那么，当你感到悲伤时，你会向谁求助？当你想要庆祝你的快乐时，你会向谁求助？她评估了人们在多大程度上依赖相对少数的人来做所有这些事情，还是依赖更多的人。她现在通过一系列研究发现
that people who've diversified their social portfolio, that is, turned to different sorts of people for different sorts of emotional experiences, tend to be a little bit happier. And so with regard to marriage in particular, we've really lumped a lot of our emotional fulfillment on this one relationship. And for many of us, we would benefit, and our marriage would actually benefit if we asked a little bit less in some respects. I love the idea of diversification and the analogy with financial diversification. I mean, so the idea, of course, is that you might have bonds in your portfolio and they
那些实现了社交组合多样化的人，也就是说，向不同的人寻求不同类型的情感体验的人，往往会稍微快乐一些。因此，就婚姻而言，我们确实把太多的情感满足寄托在这段关系上了。对于我们许多人来说，如果我们少要求一点，我们自己会受益，我们的婚姻实际上也会受益。我喜欢多样化的想法以及与金融多样化的类比。我的意思是，这个想法当然是，你的投资组合中可能有债券，它们
don't do very well and they don't grow a lot, but they're very stable. Then you might have some stocks in your portfolio that are high are high growth But they also have the potential for losing a lot and what you're suggesting is that by having different things Accomplished different parts of what you need on the whole your portfolio as a whole ends up being more stable Then if you put all your eggs in one basket You know that's right and that's a neat way of thinking about it that I hadn't fully processed previously. In some sense, what we're doing with marriage these days is we've got a heavily stock loaded portfolio. And that means that when the market is up, we make huge gains, but that's a lot of eggs
表现不是很好，增长也不多，但它们非常稳定。然后你的投资组合中可能有一些高增长的股票，但它们也有损失惨重的潜力。你建议的是，通过让不同的事物完成你所需要的部分，你的整个投资组合最终会比你把所有鸡蛋放在一个篮子里更稳定。你知道，那是对的，这是一种我以前没有完全处理过的巧妙思考方式。在某种意义上，我们现在对婚姻所做的是，我们拥有一个股票比重很高的投资组合。这意味着当市场上涨时，我们获得了巨大的收益，但那有太多的鸡蛋
to put in that one basket. And when the market goes down, we're gonna get hit pretty hard. And to some degree, that's also a reasonable metaphor for the self-expressive marriage, We're going to get hit pretty hard and to some degree that that's also a reasonable metaphor for the self-expressive marriage where we look to one person to fulfill so many of our emotional and our psychological needs The payoff can be huge, but there's a lot of risk now for people to actually consider diversifying their portfolio romantically and emotionally Presumably this also creates stresses on what we think of as marriage So if people are looking outside the marriage for emotional support or other needs,
放在那个篮子里了。当市场下跌时，我们会受到沉重的打击。在某种程度上，这也是对“自我表达型婚姻”的一个合理的隐喻，我们会受到沉重的打击，在某种程度上，这也是对“自我表达型婚姻”的一个合理的隐喻，我们指望一个人来满足我们如此多的情感和心理需求。回报可能是巨大的，但现在人们确实面临着在浪漫和情感上考虑投资组合多样化的风险。据推测，这也给我们的婚姻观念带来了压力。所以如果人们在婚姻之外寻求情感支持或其他需求，
some people are going to say, well, are you really married anymore? I think this is a valid question, and this is a complexity that comes up when you think about how an institution like marriage changes over time. I suspect that if somebody transported from 1750 to today, they might look around and say, whoa, that doesn't look like marriage. I don't even really get what you guys are doing, or better yet, if we transported back to 1750 and looked at what people were expecting
有些人会说，好吧，你还算结婚吗？我认为这是一个有效的问题，这是当你思考像婚姻这样的制度如何随时间变化时出现的一种复杂性。我怀疑如果有人从1750年穿越到今天，他们可能会环顾四周说：“哇，那看起来不像婚姻。我甚至不太明白你们在做什么”，或者更好的是，如果我们穿越回1750年，看看人们在期待什么
and how little they were looking for personal fulfillment from the marriage, we would be bewildered. So, one of the more controversial ideas that I play with in the book is when I'm talking about ways that we can ask less of the marriage. By the way, when I am doing that, I'm talking about how can we strengthen the marriage by asking less of it, one of the places that I consider is in the romantic or sexual domain. So is it reasonable for some people to consider some type of consensual non-monogamy? Now this is not cheating, that's the whole idea of consensual non-monogamy.
以及他们从婚姻中寻求个人满足感的程度有多低，我们会感到困惑。所以，我在书中探讨的更具争议性的想法之一是，当我谈论我们可以减少对婚姻的要求的方式时。顺便说一句，当我这样做时，我谈论的是我们如何通过减少对婚姻的要求来加强婚姻，我考虑的地方之一是在浪漫或性领域。那么，有些人考虑某种形式的“共识性非一夫一妻制”是否合理？现在这不是出轨，这正是“共识性非一夫一妻制”的全部理念。
This is an understanding that we don't need to have complete monogamy all the time. And you can negotiate an alternative, in fact among millennials, this is becoming an increasingly common way of thinking about the ideal relationship. So this is an ideal option, especially for people who generally are connecting pretty well, and they love each other, and they're good co-CEOs of the household together,
这是一种理解，即我们不需要一直保持完全的一夫一妻制。事实上，你可以协商一种替代方案，在千禧一代中，这正成为一种越来越普遍的理想关系思考方式。所以这是一个理想的选择，特别是对于那些通常相处得很好，彼此相爱，并且是很好的家庭共同首席执行官的夫妇，
but they're really struggling to sustain a mutually satisfying sex life together. Those are particularly good opportunities to consider could we reduce some of the disappointment and pressure by opening up the relationship in some ways that we can both agree to. It's certainly a high-risk option, but it's an option that probably will benefit some relationships.
但他们确实在努力维持一种相互满意的性生活。这些是考虑是否可以通过以双方都能同意的方式开放关系来减少一些失望和压力的特别好的机会。这当然是一个高风险的选择，但它可能对某些关系有益。
You see that you and Allison have developed a shorthand of sorts for the times that you want to communicate affection, but you changed from day to day. I want to tell her that I love her a lot, but I've got to get a belly full of wine. I'm at the Jesus Pretty Nice Girl, so they want to make a vinyl. That's Paul McCartney at the end of the Abbey Road Medley. It's like a little twenty-three second bonus track. And it's interesting. I haven't heard it in a while, and even as I listen to it, as you just played it, I sort of teared up a little bit,
你看到你和艾莉森已经为你们想要表达爱意的时候开发了一种速记法，但你们每天都在变。我想告诉她我非常爱她，但我得喝个酒足饭饱。我是耶稣那个漂亮的女孩，所以他们想做一张黑胶唱片。那是保罗·麦卡特尼在《艾比路》串烧曲末尾唱的。就像一首23秒的小奖励曲目。这很有趣。我已经有一段时间没听它了，即使我听着它，就像你刚才播放的那样，我也流下了一点眼泪，
because it's been a very significant song for my wife and me in our marriage. When we were first dating, you know, people are falling in love, and they often say, I love you or whatever, but I was very partial to this idea of belly full of wine, right? I want to tell her that I love her a lot, but I got to get a belly full of wine.
因为它对我和我妻子的婚姻来说是一首非常有意义的歌。当我们刚开始约会时，你知道，人们坠入爱河，他们经常说“我爱你”之类的，但我非常偏爱这种“酒足饭饱”的想法，对吧？我想告诉她我非常爱她，但我得喝个酒足饭饱。
And eventually saying belly full of wine was our little replacement for, I love you. And what was neat about the way we used the phrase belly full of wine is it was able to contain like a whole terabyte of information about love and respect and affection in this like one second phrase. We could turn to each other and just say belly full of wine and just really communicate so much information in that very little, just those few words. And this is an example of a broader idea
最终，“酒足饭饱”成了我们代替“我爱你”的小暗语。我们使用“酒足饭饱”这个短语的巧妙之处在于，它能够包含关于爱、尊重和感情的整整一TB的信息，就在这短短一秒钟的短语里。我们可以转向对方，只说“酒足饭饱”，就能在那短短的几个词中传达如此多的信息。这是一个更广泛理念的例子
that we don't appreciate enough, which is that every marriage has its own culture, that has its own language and its own expectations, and we can leverage the features of how culture works to benefit the marriage with a sort of emotional shorthand that can help express affection, and it can be especially crucial. If you're going through a difficult time and maybe things are getting a little hot and maybe you're on the verge of a fight, and you can say, hey, baby baby, belly full of wine and you might be able to diffuse some of what could have been a pretty problematic episode.
我们没有足够重视，那就是每一段婚姻都有自己的文化，有自己的语言和期望，我们可以利用文化运作的特点来造福婚姻，用一种情感速记法来帮助表达爱意，这可能至关重要。如果你正在经历一段困难时期，也许事情变得有点激烈，也许你正处于争吵的边缘，你可以说：“嘿，宝贝，酒足饭饱”，你也许就能化解一些本可能成为相当麻烦的插曲。
Eli Finkill is a social psychologist at Northwestern University. He's the author of the All or Nothing Marriage, How the Best Marriages Work. Eli, thanks for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me. This week's show was produced by Gabriel Azaldivia and Parth Shah and edited by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Jennifer Schmidt, Raina Cohen, Thomas Liu, Laura Correll and Adithi Bandlamudi. Our answer here of this week is Rebecca Sheer. If you have a child, you may know her as the host of the Storytelling podcast Circle Round. Rebecca helped us find actors to perform scenes for one of our episodes, why now? If you haven't heard that show, please go
伊莱·芬克尔是西北大学的社会心理学家。他是《全或无婚姻：最好的婚姻是如何运作的》一书的作者。伊莱，感谢你今天参加《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢你的邀请。本周的节目由加布里埃尔·阿扎尔迪维亚和帕斯·沙制作，塔拉·博伊尔编辑。我们的团队包括詹妮弗·施密特、雷娜·科恩、托马斯·刘、劳拉·科雷尔和阿迪蒂·班德拉穆迪。我们本周的回答者是丽贝卡·希尔。如果你有孩子，你可能知道她是故事播客《圆圈》的主持人。丽贝卡帮助我们找到了演员为我们的一集节目表演场景，为什么是现在？如果你还没听过那个节目，请回去
back and take a listen to it. We're really proud of it. You can find more hidden brain on Facebook and Twitter. If you've used any of the strategies we've discussed in our YouTube.io series, please share it with us on social media. We'd love to hear your story. I'm Shankar Vedantam, and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
听一听。我们为此感到非常自豪。你可以在Facebook和Twitter上找到更多《隐藏的大脑》。如果你使用了我们在YouTube.io系列中讨论过的任何策略，请在社交媒体上与我们分享。我们很想听听你的故事。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是NPR。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。